hey guys Pete peppers here this is a
candy crush jelly saga level 34
walkthrough it's a jam level and it can
be pretty frustrating there's a lot of
this is a weird shape here so it's kind
of hard to get the jam spread to the
corners you have this color bomb that
looks like it would be super helpful but
it's it's not that it's more cosmetic
than anything some situations you might
be able to save it and then you know
pick up stuff that you need at the
bottom other times you know you just use
it whenever you run out of other moves
it's it's not a big game-changer if you
have you know stuff you can do up here
anyways so that's why I just I'm saving
it for the moment definitely want to try
to make combos I can't do that with
these but um you know you definitely be
looking for situations to do that
because you know the key in the first
room is going to be to get out with as
many moves as you can and because even
though this one's frustrating it's
actually the easier of the two which
means that um you know you can be in for
a long and frustrating experience if you
can't get out of here fast enough so
overall you're looking for combos and
sometimes like right now you won't be
able to get them I guess here I can use
my see this is a situation where it's a
good idea to keep it till later I can
use it here to drop this down and make a
combo so I'll go ahead and do that and I
can make another raft here that's kind
of close I'm not though because I can I
can just cover this whole side but you
know take your time to think about stuff
like that don't rush through those
issues some situations though help so
here's two fish I need to I need it
they're going to cover three squares so
what I'm going to try to do is get all
the squares I can first before I set
them off
so we have three down here that we can't
get to so it'd be a bonus to be able to
get these ones at the top off first so
now that these last two we'll finish it
off for me then 33 moves it's pretty
good to move into the second room with
so here this is just this is just kind
of a mess with these staggered blockers
one of the things to keep in mind here
that you might not have noticed before
and which is a good general tip all the
time is when you're playing a board that
has jam or jelly in this case and you
have fish if you set the fish off from
dry squares like where there's nothing
underneath them then they're gonna go
after your blockers and other Drive
squares if you set them off from the
jelly they're just gonna spread jelly so
like if you're trying to get rid of
these blockers and you want to use the
fish for that then you would want to set
them off in situations like where
they're you know that they're there they
don't have jelly underneath them this is
a good match here I'm just going to do
that and you can see that that one had
Jam so it went to a jam place and then
this one's dry watch this will go to a
blocker so that's a good tip in any
jelly level you know because sometimes
there's different things that you want
to do but you know if you to spread
jelly obviously when the board's not
covered at all like the fish aren't
gonna do that much so it's not you know
the it's not a priority usually to go
ahead and do that um so I have a kind of
striped that you know like it's probably
gonna take out my lockers if I match it
with this fish so there'd be one two
three four depending on which row it
goes or I can just go ahead and do this
first
now I'm gonna want to start to spread
the jam some since you know I have the
board pretty opened up and hopefully
from there we'll be able to just go
ahead and cover the bottom half of the
board and complete the level so you know
this is it's not one of the you know
it's not it's not a super hard level it
just it can be tough whenever you know
you get kind of stuck in places and so I
just wanted to go ahead and add this to
the guide because it was the first one
that was just a regular jelly level that
I want to do discussing to show you can
get through it if you plan things out so
now we don't have any more blockers on
the board so I'm gonna want to wait to
use these fish until I get some jam over
that way you know if you can't you know
if you can't get combos or whatever and
you're having trouble it's never a bad
idea to spread the jam all on one side
that way if you get like striped candies
they'll go to the whole other side and
stuff like that so you're sort of just
making like a big stripe so that you can
spread it easier later alright so now we
can send that one off with some Jam and
there's a color bomb on a regular jam
level like this a color bomb can be just
fine by itself you don't even have to
waste them
time making a combo just because it's
gonna it's gonna spread things around
pretty well it just depends I mean
sometimes you're gonna want to but here
we're gonna get this and this should
finish off the level so that's how you
do it remember to keep in mind that
you're going to want to get out of the
first room as fast as you can save that
color bomb if you need to to use it like
I did up there and a you know instead of
your student at the beginning because
it's pretty easy to get the jam moving
through the middle stripe pay attention
to those corners on the sides and then
when you get down to the bottom
just think about how the fish you know
get rid of the blockers and if you have
enough moves up then you should be able
to cover the board so I hope this helps
make sure you like the video and
subscribe to my channel thanks